if you could be part of the crew from
any TV show or movie what crew would it
be
um maybe succession like I I would like
to be like they're just rich people who
all hate each other whatever well they
like they'd like me I could win over
Logan Roy I could win over succession
and or what's something that's like a
bunch of hot girls I can hang out with
with Charlie's Angels
so is that hot girls
I always thought like what is I don't
know I I like I only like TV shows where
I could pretend that I'm the main
character so it needs to be like a
straight white male around 26 years old
in New York City or so maybe I don't
know Seinfeld but their lives are not
that good
yeah no they're pretty I mean I'll go
succession I'd like to you know a little
move in a chicken the politics
a lot of money I could be cousin Greg